all right let's talk about Bindi Irwin
it was an important message for women
after she recently underwent surgery for
endometriosis on social media the 24
year old daughter of crocodile hunter
Steve Irwin said she had been struggling
with fatigue with pain and nausea for 10
years she said a doctor told her it was
simply something you deal with as a
woman
yeah not a male doctor I mean I would
bet that it is uh Irwin said a friend
set her on the right path that led her
to the treatment for endometriosis
tissue growing around the uterus that
can cause extreme pain Irwin shared this
post-surgery photo saying I battled for
a long time wondering if I should share
this journey it came down to the
responsibility I feel to share my story
for other women who need help
endometriosis affects one in 10 women
according to the American College of
Obstetricians and gynecologists
especially when you get tone deaf
comments like that it's something you
deal with as a woman yeah and I don't
know the gender of the Doctor Who told
her that but it's still remarkable that
somebody would say that we don't know
I think it would be one of you I think
it would be a man what are you two I'm
guessing but it is just I know but don't
assume you're right I would say with
high confidence yes but I'm glad that
she's sharing the story because if a lot
of women are suffering with something
like this it's a real issue and it's but
there is help there is oh shining a
light on